[Music]
hey everyone welcome to their
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video were going to be discussing
JK Rowling the Goblet of Fire and an
unpublished to put huge flaw that JK
Rowling encountered when she was writing
the famed novel in an old interview with
Southwest news service Rowling was
questioned further about the error as it
was something she'd revealed in a former
interview but never explained you
mentioned something in a recent
interview about a flaw in book 4 did I
oh yes I repaired it this is why book 4
nearly caused me a nervous breakdown
because for the first time ever I lost
my careful plot which I've had since
1994 I think I really should have gone
through it with a fine-tooth comb before
I started writing and I didn't I had a
false sense of security because all my
other plans had held up so well so I
sailed straight into the writing of for
having just finished Azkaban I'd written
what I thought at the time was half the
book it turns out now to pin about 1/3
of the book and I realized there was
this big hole in the middle of the plot
and had to go back and unpick and redo
that's part of the reason it's longer
than I thought it was going to be can
you say what the floor was or would that
spoil things no because that would ruin
it in the interview with Southwest news
service she discusses the errors very
broadly but it wasn't until much later
in her interview with Entertainment
Weekly that she finally revealed the
specifics of the error that she had made
when writing the book while discussing
her feelings surrounding the Goblet of
Fire and how it was much harder to write
the near the books she reveals the grave
error that she had originally made you
sat on a title for a long time - the
title thing was for much more prosaic
reason I changed my mind twice on what
it was the working title had got out
Harry Potter and their doom spell
tournament then I changed doom spell to
Triwizard Tournament then I was
teetering between Goblet of Fire and try
was a tournament in the end I preferred
Goblet of Fire because it's got that
kind of Cup of Destiny feel about it
which is the theme of the book was this
the hardest book you've had to write so
far easily why the first three books my
plan never failed me but I should have
put that plot under a microscope I wrote
what I thought was half the book and
huge gaping hole in the middle of the
plot I missed my deadline by two months
and the whole profile at the books got
so much bigger since the third book
there was an edge of external pressure
and what exactly was that gaping hole
all about I had to pull a character and
there you go
the phantom character of Harry Potter
she was a Weasley cousin she served the
same function that Rita Skeeter it now
serves Rita was always going to be in
the book but I built her up because I
needed a kind of conduit for information
outside the school originally this girl
fulfilled this purpose so there you have
it
JK Rowling wrote and then had to remove
an entire character from the book going
from halfway done back to only a third
of the way I must confess that I'm very
curious about this unknown Weasley and
why it is that JK had to do so much
backtracking to ensure that this
character was completely erased from the
book why not reframe the character why
removed them altogether
according to JK Rowling his website the
unknown cousin of the Weasleys was
Mafalda Weasley the daughter of the
second cousin who's a stockbroker
mentioned in the Philosopher's Stone
Mafalda however would turn out to be the
most unpleasant child mrs. Weasley you
had ever met and she would prove to
continually butt heads with the
protagonists her folder was supposed to
convey certain information about the
Death Eaters to Harry Ron and Hermione
because as a nosy eavesdropping so
therein he likes to impress she does not
keep her mouth shut when she overhears
their sons and daughters talking but
Rowling ended up taking her out because
she felt that the character was out of
place
unfortunately however bright I made her
there were obvious limitations to what
an eleven-year-old constitute at school
could discover whereas Rita Skeeter whom
I subsequently built up to fulfil more
fall dysfunction was much more flexible
and that's it for this video did you
guys know about the unknown Weasley if
you guys enjoy the content please like
the video and subscribe to support the
channel until next time you're a wizard
Harry
[Music]